but check out this first story this one
hits close to home
citing threats mayor lori lightfoot
defends
ban on protesters on her block i have a
right to make sure that my home is
secure
now this story is particularly funny
because doesn't everybody have a right
to make sure their home is secure
they do and i decided to do a little
digging
not particularly difficult and over on
the nra website they actually have an
article they wrote from just three days
ago
chicago's mayor lightfoot hammering away
the second amendment
i find this particularly hilarious at a
time when she's telling you
you don't have a right to protect
yourself we got to get the guns off the
street
and she literally this is amazing she's
amazing she says that donald trump
i'm sorry says the federal government
was uniquely qualified to help with
chicago's gun problem
by enacting common sense gun control yet
when donald trump offers
actual resources i get it she's probably
talking about congress
but when trump comes out and says i can
help with the gun violence she says no
i want the federal government to do
something like enacting gun control
yeah she doesn't want help she wants her
political agenda yep
and this is this is this has been
chicago as long as i can remember
that i i don't know how true this is
because it was something i heard when i
was a kid from my dad
the local politicians all have they
either have armed security
or they're armed themselves they could
get guns when no one else could well
there was like a supreme court ruling
forcing all these states to recognize
you you can't do this you can't ban
these weapons
chicago is forced to actually allow
people to carry weapons in response
all of these businesses started putting
up no guns allowed on the doors of all
of the buildings everywhere
so you know we look at this story and
i'll start waiting a second but this is
a perfect example
of using city resources to guard her
home
while telling everyone else no guns for
you and then what
what happens chicago is all the all the
people who are dying to gun crime
i mean these are these are the people
who are committing this they're
criminals there are guns in chicago
foreign oh yeah so you've got these
criminals that are going around not
caring about the law killing people
and regular citizens are the ones who
are punished because of it yup that
sounds about right
sounds chicago let's read the story they
say mayor lori lightfoot defended the
chicago police department's ban on
protesters being able to demonstrate on
the block where she lives
telling reporters thursday that she and
her family at times require heightened
security
because of threats she receives daily
lightfoot refused to elaborate on the
specific threats
but said she receives them daily against
herself her wife and her home
comparisons to how the police department
has protected previous mayor's homes
such as rahm emanuel's ravenswood
residents
are unfair because quote this is a
different time like no other
lightfoot told reporters i think that
residents of the city understanding the
nature of the threats that we are
receiving on a daily basis on a daily
basis understand
i have a right to make sure that my home
is secure lightfoot said
lifewood and chicago police
superintendent david brown were asked at
an unrelated news conference about a
tribune report
noting police have banned protesters
from demonstrating on her block in the
logan square neighborhood
ordering officers to arrest anyone who
refuses to leave
the directive surfaced in a july email
from then shakespeare
uh shakespeare district commander melvin
roman to officers under his command
it did not distinguish between the
peaceful protesters lightfoot regularly
says she supports
and those who might intend to be
destructive but ordered that after a
warning is given to demonstrators
it should be locked down i absolutely
love this because
she's talking about how she gets death
threats yeah okay if you get threats and
you wanna have a security guard
i get it you wanna have one patrol car
out in front of your house
that i understand we do that for
witnesses you want to have the cops
block off your street and arrest anyone
who doesn't leave even peaceful
demonstrators you're a hypocrite of the
highest order
yeah i can't even wrap my head around uh
how hypocritical she's being
even from going to get a haircut at the
beginning of this
i started to think wow this lady really
really does not believe a single word
she says
and she absolutely does not that's all
of them isn't it at this point i have no
faith that any of them actually believe
what they're telling us
it is but she's especially egregious
about this i feel like she's really she
does not care
i don't know why i'm not i think because
there were a bunch of other
governors and mayors who went out and
got haircuts yeah and i think she was
the first
i don't know because i think whitmer did
it these people man they're
they're how do you describe them
fascistic despots
don't give these people power anymore i
mean this is this is insane to me
activists and police sources could not
cite instances when the city repeatedly
locked down her predecessor emmanuel's
block against protesters
the kenwood block where former president
barack obama lived with his family when
his primary residence was in chicago
was shut down for access only by
residents after his election
but lightfoot said such comparisons
don't make any sense
after brown referenced the ongoing
coronavirus pandemic as well as civil
unrest
that may have flared since george since
the george floyd killing
at the hands of minneapolis police i'm
not going to make any excuses for the
fact that given the threats i have
personally received given that you know
i get it i get it
i make no apologies whatsoever for this
doesn't she
sound just like one of these twitter
whiny sjws
she absolutely does yeah like well you
know your words are speech so you should
be banned i'm allowed to say whatever i
want because i'm fighting for justice
see when it's me it's different when it
was those other guys that were actually
not still still not particularly good
like rahm emanuel
right it's it's these
these people who are running are
probably the worst i've ever seen in
terms of saying whatever they have to
say
to get whatever they want do you think
that's the case or do you think that the
coronavirus is just bringing this out
because i'm starting to think it's the
latter i think that they're because i've
thought for a long time that any kind of
crisis like this will
lend itself to fascistic leaders who
really want to capitalize on it but
trump's not doing it
he's not it's true and they're
complaining about it
yeah so i guess that shows they
i mean i feel like it's kind of beating
a dead horse to say but
they project oh absolutely they're the
racists there's the despots
and they're pointing the finger at trump
and the republicans and screeching
while we literally i mean look at this
article what journalists could deny this
the beltway sjw left i guess yeah that
hate trump
i'm reading a chicago tribune this is
like one of the this is the premier
chicago news outlet the tribune is
famous
saying straight up the mayor is i have a
right to make sure my home is secure
i mean you do and so do the rest of us
so here's what i try here's what i when
i wanted what i wanted to do when i saw
that she was doing this
i know that chicago is extremely
restrictive illinois is extremely
restrictive
i said who better than to tell me about
the laws
in illinois and chicago than the nra now
not
never been the biggest fan of the nra
but i'll i'll state straight up i became
a member of the nra and another gun
rights advocacy group because now i own
weapons
because i don't believe that i can trust
these people to take care of me
i don't believe the that the police have
the no no disrespect
to the police in general but when
someone tried breaking in here
one of the cops straight up said if it
were me i'd answer the door with a
shotgun
of course and i'm like i don't know if
you can do that in new jersey
because this is this is like a
semi-castle doctrine state my
understanding is that in jersey you have
to flee
yeah and if you can't flee then you can
defend yourself which is kind of just
like normal self-defense i guess
yeah but there's there are some states
that have nothing yeah
like there's no laws at all i guess just
falls to self-defense but anyway
so i go to the nra website and instead
of finding i mean
that they do have the map of the country
and like the different gun laws
quite literally one of the one of the uh
most recent articles
is that mayor lightfoot is hammering
away at the second amendment
to me that's fascinating i don't think
this is gonna whatever whatever it is
they're doing it's not gonna stop
you know like taking away weapons from
law abiding citizens is not going to
stop crime and i think that's completely
obvious
right and i gotta admit to my my opinion
on two-way like
veered straight right after after
starting with covet and then the riots
it started with the guy trying to break
in yep and then some somebody made a
meme
and it was you you the the you guys have
probably seen the meme of the two dogs
one's super ripped and one's all whiny
and scrawny yeah
and then it was like tim pool in 2019
and it was a scrawny little
like sad dog saying help me please
someone's trying to break into my house
or was like someone's trying to break up
my house help and then the next one was
all ripped with a bunch of guns and it
said tim pool 2020.
if you vote for this you get what you
deserve i'm like well you know what man
talk about a wake-up call someone tries
to break in mass riots
pandemic and what am i supposed to do or
say right well it's not just you because
we've talked about this a few times
because people are buying it up and i
think with austin peterson who was
saying you're
four months too late to be picky in any
way about the kind of a weaponry you get
ammo shortage yeah dude gun shortage gun
shortage
running out the local gun shop near us
they're stripped
clean they put a bunch of squirt guns in
their display case
it's actually really funny it's just
empty it's all empty
and i was talking to them because i had
a bunch of recommendations for
you know like really good self-defense
weapons
handguns and stuff they didn't they were
sold out yeah i think they had
i'm not i'm not a gun person so forgive
me if i get this wrong 1911
a couple of those that's what it's
called i think so and they have and then
they had like a really
massive revolver yeah but uh that was
that was that was basically that
barely any i mean and now i'm reading
ammo shortages and all this stuff
but i'm sure people outside of chicago
are going about getting legal weapons
yeah mayor lightfoot however doesn't
like the fact they have gun violence
there's been a big uptick in crime in
all these major cities which most of you
know by now
and she's blaming it on the massive
surge of gun purchases it's been
interesting to watch all the articles
talk about
they make the direct link between the
increased number of guns being purchased
and the increasing amount of gun crime
i was like this is this is faulty this
is a this is incorrect
because i'm sure it's george who's 45
and concerned about his three kids and
his wife
right and they're living just you know
the outskirts of the city so they went
to get personal protection
and that's the cause of criminals
shooting people in new york city that
was what made george do it he just went
absolutely insane the second he bought
that weapon to defend his home and his
wife
is i think this is how many of these uh
people like lightfoot
must think that a sane rational person
you know george is a plumber
and you know he comes home from work one
day and he sees the news
so he goes to buy a gun then as soon as
his hand grips the the
you know the the as soon as he picks it
up just all of a sudden he starts
shaking his eyes glow
and then he just goes on a rampage like
that's what they think is happening yeah
you know i'm sure there's a lot of gun
advocates who know all the stuff
way better than i do but especially now
because
with the increase in crime with the
massive surge of of
of sales i'm certainly being thrown
straight into the you know the deep end
colds cold water just right in but
it's it's not legal gun owners that are
doing anything and you know lori
lightfoot knows that's not the case
she knows people don't go crazy as soon
as they purchase a weapon you know how i
know she knows this
because she's hired a whole bunch of
them to surround her house and to keep
her
safe that's literally their role it's
shockingly hypocritical i love how she
says that she wants the federal
government
i mean this is it's the gist of the
story from the nra they say mayor laura
life
has consistently demanded more gun
control as the answer to the epidemic of
violence
that her city is experiencing in an
interview on july 18th for example the
mayor was clear
the only way we're going to really get
at the problem in a profound way
is to have federal laws in place that
require background checks and strengthen
the penalties
for people who pick up guns and wreak
havoc in our communities
okay i went to go buy a gun that took me
like a month
yep and i wouldn't call it hard i would
call it tedious
menial is that the right word yeah lots
of like um busy work
a lot of busy work paperwork bouncing
back and forth and then there were some
you know hold ups
and apparently i'm on some delayed list
or something yeah
really funny i don't know if i care a
whole lot recently james o'keefe who
many of you may be familiar with from
project veritas
he tried to go buy a gun turns out he
was on an fbi list
falsely you know so he filed the lawsuit
he won congratulations to james he can
now go buy a weapon
i found out it takes me like five days
to get cleared
and the shop told me that it's always
delayed my background check
but and i was like i don't know if i
care that is weird though
i'll buy it i can wait five days i'm not
freaking out but it is weird
and when i see things like this i'm like
what i don't i'm not entirely sure what
she's talking about background checks
because i had to go it was crazy filling
out all these forms for the federal
government
not just the state i had to fill out
this form for the feds or whatever
yeah you basically have to do everything
twice right yeah yeah because new
jersey's nuts
yes i guess they call new jersey one of
the evil seven
or something yeah it's not good it's one
of the worst states for this oh
definitely and i actually filled out the
paper the same paperwork you did
and they never got back to me i went and
i was fingerprinted and everything and i
know i'm out of i'm from
out of state my id was from out of state
no one gave me any static about it at
the time they just never got back to me
so i actually need to follow up with you
yeah you can just like kind of let it
fall into a black hole
it's really cool because i got my what
is it the federal license or whatever
yeah there's so many people in the chat
are probably like tim this is what it's
called and i'm like i don't know that's
it's all right
but i went i went and bought a gun like
a bunch of them actually we are
equipped yeah we are and so anyway back
to the story is what i love she's
talking about the federal government
needing to enact these gun laws when in
reality the problem is
criminals who are already breaking the
law
like you have you you have laws in
chicago you have criminals who have
broken the law in chicago
making more laws won't change the fact
these people have already broken the law
i don't understand what she's trying to
say
it just makes no sense except for the
fact that she's you know look these
people in chicago are
rather despotic i love that word by the
way i do too desperately it's very
fitting for this year yeah despotic
so this is i i love to to go back to
this one oh man mayor lori lightfoot i
don't need
leadership lessons from donald trump
apparently you do
literally test proved that was false
yeah no i'm sorry i think she actually
does take a look this is from uh
the situation room there she is got a
little biden for president
behind her well i'm i'm glad to see that
she's supporting that she says that's
just ridiculous hyperbolic rhetoric
he is at a race to the bottom chicago
mayor lori lightfoot reacts to president
trump using the line
blood-stained sidewalks of chicago on
the campaign trail
what we have here is a fundamentally
what we have here is a fundamentally
failed leadership
on every major issue i'm sorry man
no it just is she referring to her
leadership or
his i hope she's referring to herself
yeah that would be surprisingly
self-reflective
the other night um from uh most of you
who who caught the show the other night
we had jack murphy on yeah
and jack's from chicago i did not
realize that again neither delayed
i forgot i i'm pretty sure he told me
before but
and a bunch of people here after the
show are all from chicago yeah and it
was really funny how all of us
are no longer in chicago indeed and i
know it's not for all the same reasons
but
i mean for me and i can i'm pretty sure
at least one or two other people
it's it's it look the food's fantastic
right
one thing chicago does right you know
you look at what is what does la do they
got hollywood they got acting stuff new
york i guess they got finance chicago's
got food
yeah they got hot dogs they got italian
beef they got jardinera deep dish pizza
cheesecake mm-hmm garrett's beer
cuisine yeah but the violence is too
much yeah i've been i've been
uh oh you know i was in south korea once
and this is a really funny story i'm
from chicago
yeah everybody knows it cause i bring it
up all the time huh yes that's right i'm
a mixed race high school dropout from
the south side of chicago you've heard
that one once or twice
and i remember talking to some people
from south africa who were in south
korea they left
and they told me it's not as bad as
everyone thinks in south africa i've
only been carjacked
like five or six times wow it's like
wait
what whoa yeah so if it's what you're
used to
i'll count my lucky stars that uh that's
not some person
my experience in chicago but i've had
people who have been you know i know
people who have
like i know a lot of people died maybe
not a lot maybe that's a
handful in chicago people i grew up with
and
you know more like friends of friends
and then i remember i'll hear these
stories and like man did you hear
yeah yeah yeah some it's just senseless
gun violence for sure
but these are people who are already
breaking the law in a city with
the cops got a bad reputation they do
they have some corruption
yeah to put it mildly yeah some crazy
crazy stuff and i think i think
chicago only ever elects corrupt
politicians
why is that do you think i don't know
man a legacy of like al capone
or something maybe so yeah they're
trying to carry that on maybe
you know in in brazil they did this
thing called pacification to the favelas
the favelas are shanty towns and so
there's a really interesting thing about
brazil and this is what they told me
when i was down there
the rich people lived by the beach and
so the poor people were forced to climb
the hills
whereas in many other places living on
the hill
is for the rich people it's fortified
it's safe you can see everything but
you know living by the port and being on
the beach i guess when you're in you
know copacabana or something
it's preferable so you end up with these
shanty towns where people are literally
building on top of each other
and eventually what happens is because
it's kind of crazy
somebody would build a house and then
someone would walk through that house
to build a house on top of their house
that's how crazy it is
yeah sometimes it rains and the houses
just wash away oh my gosh
but they've been they've been trying to
fix them and they call it a pacification
or reclamation because they've just kind
of let them do whatever they want
they've formed their own leadership and
so they had these different groups
the like um i think i was correct the
last time i talked about the bopay
this is like a tactical swat squad like
these are the guys with the skull
balaclavas
oh going in and pushing out the gangs
are they the ones that use the live ammo
i believe they have they're all using
live ammo wow
i bring them up not to suggest we do
anything like that
heavens no but it's interesting how
chicago
has done nothing in all of its all of
this time
to literal like nothing literally
nothing it's like you don't gotta go
like like brazil
marching in the the storm troopers with
live ammo and rifles around corners with
a special training
you send in some cops and and and you
you stand in some street corners and
you talk to the community leaders you
have some meetings you ask them
you know what they think is appropriate
but for whatever reason maybe chicago
does that
maybe they do i don't know i did an
interview with this woman who said the
problem they have is illegal gun
guns and it's difficult for them to
legally own guns
and she was this was really interesting
this was a black woman who was
advocating for
gun rights in the black community
because she felt legal gun ownership
would protect people from random gun
violence
that was a really interesting take point
coming from the city
yeah well i i have a i have i think i
have more respect for the aldermen in
chicago than i do
for like me uh mayor lightfoot i think
that she's a little bit crazy but the
aldermen seem to be like on the ground
with the people in the communities
was that kind of your experience i mean
i never met my alderman whatever i
really met him because i remember when
this first went down the aldermen were
like beside themselves they were talking
to
oh yeah but they were cussing her out on
these zoom calls and i was like you tell
her because
the audio leaked yeah someone needs to
talk about this and they were like doing
it
it's because she doesn't care in my
opinion
about anyone in that city but i really
don't i mean look
look at this this is this is the story
we were referencing earlier
chicago mayor lori lightfoot defends
hair stylist visit amid coronavirus
outbreak
i'm the public face of this city i'm on
national media and i'm out in the public
eye mayor lori lightfoot said
i don't care i have a point to make
about laurie lightfoot's hair
and it's not going to be very
complimentary her hair
needs a little more than a hair styling
i'm afraid i don't i don't know
i'm sorry lady i i don't have the
greatest hair either but
going out for a hair styling in the
middle of a pandemic after you told
everyone else not to do it is just
disgusting honestly like give me a break
she's all in all just kind of a bad
person i guess yeah i'm starting you
know but
but hold on hold on to be fair i can
throw it to new york city oh
okay mayor de blasio's wife is branded a
disgrace
for having a staff of 14 including a 70
000
videographer who filmed her bacon
cookies while crime
soars after one billion dollar nypd cuts
and trash piles up on the streets as 22
000 city
city job face the chop i love their
headlines
oh that's the daily mail yeah but so
this is the question i had for you
because i've heard people talking about
this i was like you know what
my initial assumption bill de blasio's
rich isn't he yeah he's a landlord he
owns multiple properties something he
gets like eight grand a month in rent
yeah i don't know how rich he is but i
was like
so what so he hired a bunch of people
for his wife yeah so i looked this up
and this is city money
they're spending over a million dollars
a year for her little staff
oh despotism yeah more despotism so it's
really nice so
i'm glad that they're giving laurie
lightfoot some competition but this is
not really what i wanted so is garcetti
yeah it's it's everywhere man i had a
friend hit me up that uh he left san
francisco
yeah and i asked him you know what's
going on industry's gone
the city is just wasted man
so it's it's i think it's funny when
people say
it's not an issue of the democrats it's
that bigger cities tend to be run by
democrats and i'm like okay
how does that change what i said no that
changes nothing right right right and
and and the citation i have to use in
san diego yeah so i ended up looking
into
uh ballot pedia it's this excellent
website that tracks
you know electoral politics and stuff i
was looking at the top
sites uh i'm sorry the top cities for
crime
and the top cities per capita and i
think per capita there's
i don't i think there's like one
republican city
i could be wrong i'm not sure if it's
per capita or not but uh
it's you're basically not going to find
republican cities that are managed this
way yeah as i recall there was
there were two republican cities and
then one independent-run
city that were kind of on the level of
any of these democratic cities
i was like there must just be a
difference in the way republicans manage
things because this isn't the same it's
not on the same level
i don't understand how people stand for
this i really don't get it
i mean to be fair i'm leaving
like we're we're we're packing up shop i
got great news everybody the
the upgrade is happening we've finally
you know
landed this deal and it's like now we're
we're good to go
but you know what i am leaving which
means
you know what may happen in cities like
new york where everyone's already fled
and places like chicago where people
have long fled the only people left are
the people who like the status quo and
the status quo is violence and
corruption
so you look at new york city and
the middle-class and upper-class people
are gone
and now all that's left are people who
just vote for
the the corrupt government officials
chicago with all the violence
i mean i left a long time ago maybe the
problem is
people like me refusing to stay and vote
these people out yeah you know so what
sorry when i leave chicago then i'm not
there to say no
when i leave you know new jersey now i'm
not going to be here say no
no to governor phil murphy is that his
name yeah that's an interesting point
cause i was watching will wit because he
lives in california
i read one of his tweets and he said i
am staying here
so that i can make a positive change
here and i was like you know what that's
really brave
i can appreciate that if you have a
platform and if you have a way to make a
change where you live
maybe that's the right approach i don't
know and i encourage people to get out
of the big cities but at the same time
it's like
maybe there's something to staying and
trying to make a positive difference
you turned red again did i oh tomato
lady
oh nice we we we fixed the camera we did
i swear
it happens i don't know we have to fix
the camera again naturally so you guys
who are watching you get to see uh
tomato face lydia
tomato so i i think what all of this
is there's an overlap here we have
another story that i want to get into
because this also has to do with schools
and then we can segue into schools
but what gets a lot of these people
elected
they whisper everything you want to hear
into your ears
they tell you all of these great things
about diversity and inclusion social
justice we're here for you and you know
what's crazy is that
once you give someone something it's
impossible to take away oh yeah
so you have people who become gradually
more dependent
they become dependent on the system so
i've i've been a big fan
of social programs government social
programs 100
however we do them wrong oh yeah the way
the way i've always described it is
you know at some point something
happened where the analogy is you got to
cut on your arm
and so what do you do well you clean it
you put a band-aid on it
then eventually you take the band-aid
off you clean it again and you put a
band-aid back on it
so you got to keep checking on it
removing the band-aid cleaning it see if
it works and then trying to get it to
heal again
what we do in these cities is we just
keep slapping more band-aids on top of a
festering gangrenous wound as it spreads
and gets worse
right interesting so what what should we
do instead see my my issue was that i
feel like a lot of the stuff was done at
the federal level when it shouldn't have
been
like and i think lori lightfoot is
completely wrong i don't think that gun
control
like this in her own little tiny city
should be legislated at the federal
level tiny city
you know what i mean it's not the united
states of america right
she's she's a little bit i feel like
she's just pushing her own agenda
because she is
much better suited to talk to the people
in her city about making positive
changes to reduce gun violence
no what i what i see this as is somebody
who is like
i want to have power yep and what do i
need to say to get it
unfortunately like i mentioned people
like me would leave
when i see you know look how many what
is it like three of the past governors
of illinois went to prison
some some stupid number yeah and then
and then i remember
uh someone some so uh i was telling this
story i think i was telling the story
the other day about these politicians in
chicago
this guy who was trying to like
manipulate me or use me or something for
his real estate development i don't know
they they were floating's idea that i
would run for alderman in a hip in a
hipster area
as a young skateboarder who could
attract all these young people
it was just floated to me and i was told
by
you know my my family all of the
aldermen are in prison
for corruption don't get involved in
chicago politics then i have a
completely wrong
impression of chicago alderman because
the ones that i heard the mo the loudest
ones i've heard were just yelling at me
or lightfoot and they're like you're
doing this all right i like
i like that they yell at lightfoot
absolutely it was this one guy forgot
his name but it was a leaked audio
recording a phone call where he was like
she was cussing at him and he was like
why are you cussing at me i'm telling
you like you're doing it wrong blah blah
blah
it was about the writers they raised the
bridges the rioters
you know flood into the neighborhoods
and he's like keep them downtown
look if it's like you send them into
neighborhoods they go and smash up
residential properties
that's people people live it's like i
get it's bad no matter what they do with
vandalism like no matter what they're
breaking it's bad
but wouldn't it better wouldn't they be
better off downtown
yeah not for her financial interests
yeah so these
so here's what i see i see a bunch of
people who
have been empowered and this is probably
why i think
it's it's it's connected very much so to
the intersectionalist stuff
it's it's almost the same thing go to
somebody who's not a billionaire
and say it's not your fault you should
be rich
and they go you're right because i'm
special that's right you are
it's patriarchy in fact it's is
heteronormative
what's a missing one racist misogynist
says heteronormative patriarchy yeah
something like that
is that is it i'm missing one of the one
of their words i don't know whatever
the point is it's really easy to go to
someone and say it's not your fault it's
everyone else's fault yeah
and it's really easy for us to fall back
and just accept that because it's easy
out
i think that's what cities cities have
been breeding because
they keep promising people things to get
elected
and they drive down the path of we're
going to give you more stuff
it's going to come from someone else and
then you end up with socialism
and then the system collapses because
nobody's making stuff
and then you start over because after
the system collapse collapses you go
into
i don't even want to call it
laissez-faire capitalism because it's
not really
you know if you build up a capitalist
system it can function
i'm not you know i'm not an absolute fan
i think you need regulations and stuff
just for health and environmental stuff
but after after you know ukraine's a
really great example
after the fall of communism just a bunch
of guys with guns shut up and took
everything
yeah and so now you have oligarchs well
that sounds not preferable
definitely not preferable so i think
unless something changes unless
people in cities have i guess a
reckoning a wake-up call
it will just keep going on this path but
but maybe maybe
uh what we see with lori lightfoot is
exactly the
the system in you know as it works it's
going to rebound
maybe they're going to be people in
chicago who always vote democrat who now
see this woman
using police as a private security i
mean listen banning protests in front of
our houses
is a constitutional violation the feds
there could be a
doj probe of like 1a violations or
something like that i'd imagine i don't
know how it works whatever
but i could imagine they they could do
something yeah because she is
she literally says she is not
discriminating between peaceful
protesters
and writers well she just i don't know
if she said that
she's just not saying she said she
doesn't care
she she was saying she she doesn't care
if you're told to disperse and you don't
get rounded up and arrested yeah to me
that sounds like a 1a violation in the
making
it's it's i mean i think she literally
just violated one eight yeah
the threat the threat alone could deter
someone from speaking their mind yeah
exactly
so maybe the people of chicago are going
to see her
romping about doing whatever she wants
failing and be like
that's it we're done and we could see
what happened
in in the uk maybe the people of these
big cities
vote red and just say enough that's why
i i mean you look at the dnc
right i think right now the dnc is
happening and and you guys are here
because you guys are awesome and the dnc
is
they're smart awful yep yeah but i guess
biden's gonna do his speech or something
but they they simultaneously call antifa
peaceful protesters
and then they say the pledge of
allegiance
it's it's to me it's just completely
hypocrite it's it's it
it's nonsense it's nonsensical they have
no platform yeah they're trying to
pander where they
think the audience lies so when it comes
to the national media that tends to
be biased towards antifa they say
peaceful protest or a million times
but then when they're doing the dnc
which is going to be targeting mom and
pops in the suburbs they say i pledge
allegiance to the flag and they said
under god whoa yes they did oh my
goodness
that surprised me man yeah do you
remember when andrew cuomo was like
america's
never great he's in there in the dnc
talking about how wonderful
america is and how we've got to build
back better
bill what are you building back from if
you don't think that america was ever
great
what are you going with there well they
destroyed the cities so they want to
build them back better right
okay so it's their own destruction that
okay i
look i think build back better is an
admission of guilt i think so
think about it we we've seen new york
city destroyed
they meanwhile that you know the mayor's
wife has this
really expensive staff filming or bake
cookies it's the most ridiculous and
corrupt thing i've ever seen
french revolution not the most corrupt
thing i've ever seen but it's it's
pretty corrupt
and he's he's talking about how he wants
to buy up all these buildings and turn
him to affordable housing yeah he wants
to build back better
oh yeah i got it in his mind okay yeah
in his mind thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show
live monday through friday at 8 p.m if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you